yeah you told us about the marathon's I
have to I have to talk about that
because it's it's really it's almost
forgive me unbelievable because it's
it's really so many marathons it's 43
marathons in 51 days I did 43 yeah how
long is the marathon is 42 killers and
how long time do you spend if your world
record holder is 2 hours I took up to 12
hours something so the point was it
didn't matter cuz I would stop and meet
people on the way
in fact I'd find reasons to stop people
would say did you enjoy the running I
said no I enjoyed the stopping I like
the adventure of it it's like a big
quest it's like a you know it's like a
Viking quest or some of the ancient
myths you know as I was going out there
and I would run one interesting I ran
the first one and I go hey I've done one
manner that's good and then the next day
I run the second and I thought I could
stop now and I could talk for people for
years I said yes I did too in two days
once but but you did run yeah this is
what no I ran and I walked and I
staggered whatever needed to be done so
it's not it's not speedrunning it's
endurance what was your shape when you
started the same as it finished it
really didn't do much
I did hope that I've become skinny as a
rake that didn't work you need to do
fast-twitch type stuff but I did it got
I got after ten rather than so it gets
easier in case you ever trying it around
ten and eleven days and after that I got
my brain got ready and go ok ok that's
what he's doing is it sometimes boring
yes that's wrong it can be but I do
stand-up comedy
and I have to talk about something so
I'm actually fascinated I know about
wars and about people and I'm studying
them and I'm going into politics as well
because I don't know because I'm going
into politics
seven years I go in seven years seven
years have to go for the the the
selection with the Labour Party for
either Mayor of London or MP there will
be two elections into 2020 and it's not
a joke
you're actually planning to you know
unlike you google it I've been talking
about it sometime yeah Mayor of London
Marilyn and all a member of Parliament's
if not there could be a Labour man Mayor
of London who comes in in 2016 and if he
wants to or she wants to carry on then I
don't want to run against them in my
first election anything how would that
be if if you were to be be Mayor of
London yeah would you be able then
seriously what do you think you would be
able to do to dress like a woman as you
do sometimes yeah I wear whatever I want
to wear or whatever I feel like wearing
because that is my right in the United
Nations Charter it isn't actually
well plain because I think I could write
it in some way but you know what I'm
wearing does it matter how good a job
I'm doing it's what matters so the fact
I have painted nails I've just been
around the world so people look at you
go oh wow and still if you did would
would it be fatter or masculine oh who
mark up the the the general Merkel well
the way I'm looking the style I'm going
at both the party a woman start there
not my political area I have to go for
Hillary Clinton I have to go who's gonna
be wearing makeup so I'm going to be
it's gonna be whatever I can do and I
will be 58 going for this so I may just
be painting my nails and saying I am a
transvestite but it doesn't matter it
doesn't it's not to do with the politics
it's to do with me being open and honest
which i think is part of the world that
we're looking for we're going to be
joined by some other people now yeah and
I'm gonna say something in Scandinavian
but then we're gonna speak English just
to be polite it is amazing that you're
speaking English in the first place a
word of Swedish Danish or Norwegian
because you guys are so good at it it
actually blows our minds we are minds
oblong
you